este es el presidente joe biden digo
además de si solo eres el
solo el principio y la sanción
contrata al ministro del año pasado
escuela revolucionaria te fijas en mi tiene
met gold en pd a liszt que entre diez
para imitarlo grecia en manus de los
cubanos y específicamente san sanciona
choque de pandillas en barolo peschiera
precisamente el ministro de su
revolucionario para respetar y le ministro
era el sentido exterior cubanos reccia
solo mary ai look fue infundado y eso es
esta sanción debe imponerse sí
autoimpone r's y noticias falsas por los
los manifestantes contra el crimen chocan durante
la protesta de black light mario esta
la presión se produce sólo para el tono impone
sancionar este verano el congreso de la
hoja republicana del congreso i si si
distancia desde el ala progresiva del
democracia eso es lo que se mantuvo
comprometer al presidente Joe Biden que
leo antara y embarque como el suyo
momento no se cuando fue diputado
presidente barack obama cambio y ahi
mencionar que esta presión viene
del representante ambos politicos cubanos
la escuela no es florida pero analista si
dicen que era la politica
estaban centrados en 3 de cada 4 noticias del gobierno
impone rey impone penas por cambio
un severo es un argumento también
precisamente sino sancionar chocar con el
oriente tiene cuentas con el régimen mayo
justificar la máxima expresión sobre la base
infracción de reggio su manus de
política del régimen cubano para
la información